good morning Hank it's question Tuesday
the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters while sitting in
a real airport what's going on with the
nerdfighter event in Chicago on 8 808
the Harold Washington library is going
to try to accommodate everyone for the 2
p.m. event but if for some reason you
can't get in don't worry there will be
awesome available for you and then we'll
see you at 4 o'clock for the wizard rock
concert in Grant Park and then at 8:08
p.m. at the beam where Amy cross
Rosenthal is gonna make awesome happen
more info there or there and now back to
the airport overall do you think the
flashlight is a worthwhile invention
yeah who's opposed to flashlights moles
can you give me a law book summary of a
Jane Austen book my family gots class
but no money I Can Has husband do you
and Hank have any other siblings just me
and me and us do you get nervous when
you talk in front of a large group of
people yeah extremely actually when I
look at video of myself speaking in
front of large groups of people I always
look a little bit like how I looked when
I was in seventh grade and I attempted
to fast dance anyway I hope everybody
likes my new book Paper Towns why are
you only charging 3 dollars and 99 cents
for the new paperback of an abundance of
katherines
well first I feel like books are
generally too expensive and second I
would rather have readers than have
money and third I kind of think of it as
a way of thanking you in advance for all
the money I'm about to ask you to spend
on Paper Towns how do you keep so fresh
degree and thanks for noticing what
college did you attend Kenyon high
school Indian spring school who would
win an arm-wrestling you or Hank I think
it's possible that we might both lose I
subscribe to this channel by mistake how
do you unsubscribe this sucks okay first
you have to write a letter to the
nerdfighter council then Hank does this
laparoscopic operation where he goes in
with a special tube and he sucks all the
awesome out of your body and replaces it
with like blood and organs and stuff and
then we got to hit you with a memory
zapper so you permanently forget to be
awesome are you and Hank the same person
yes we're both Mary Tyler Moore obscure
be 2.0 joke obscure P 2.0 joke what do a
racecar in a kayak have in common
they're both palindromes riddle pwned
what would your autobiography be called
does my eye look okay to you the John
Green story or else as the puffs rise if
the John Green story when did you first
realize you were a total nerd
oh people are perfectly happy to point
it out to me pretty early on how did you
propose to the Yeti there's this writer
the Yeti really likes named hendrik
hertzberg and I happened to meet him at
a conference and so I asked him to sign
a book for me and he signed it - Sara
will you marry John Greene I think it's
a good idea best wishes and Rick
Hertzberg I mean maybe she could have
said no to me but no one can say no to
hendrik hertzberg if you were a
superhero who would you be
probably pants power the superhero with
power pants created by my secret sister
Debbie how soon after you finish one
book do you start on the next one pretty
much the next day I'm always worried
that if I wait any longer I'll just stop
what's your favorite Hank song probably
Helen Hunt although my Dark Horse pick
would be I sold your dog on eBay because
I just love it you can kind of like rock
out to it get kind of soulful like we
both know that we had bills to pay hey I
promised you I'd never sing again but I
was lying do your parents want you guys
on YouTube no they're too busy watching
fred and Smosh of course they watch us
they're our parents can I get a copy of
the green-green manifesto yes I just
posted it at the Ning will there be
another project for awesome secret
brother Tom didn't call it the first
annual project for awesome for nothing
did Hank get better grades than you yes
what does Hank actually do like for
money huh good question I never really
thought about it maybe he like robbed
banks or something can't you just see
Hank robbing banks alright I need all of
you to get down on the ground
contemplate the size of your carbon
footprints and give me all your money
because daddy needs some new corndogs
what's your favorite thing to put on
toast bubbles the nerdfighting puppy
what was your college application essay
about all I'm going to say is that my
college application essay would
literally have been better if I had put
a sea lion inside of a sealed room for a
week with a typewriter actually aside
from the complexity of acquiring and
feeding a sea lion for a week that is a
great idea for a college application
essay nerdfighters I'm going to do
another one of these next week so please
leave your questions and comments
Hank thanks for being awesome and I'll
see you on 8808